To begin writing our task for GET
method, I'm still in this split view.
And on the left, I have the task for
GET method that we're going to
implement in the TMDB client.
And on the right,
we're looking at the get SessionID
method in the login view controller.
And if you don't know how to use
the split view, you just need to select
the assistant editor here and
then you can select which files you want
using these file navigators here at
the top for the left and right views.
Now, what we want to do is pull the
common code elements out of getSessionID
from here on the right into
the taskForGETMethod on the left.
Now as we stated earlier, each method
may have different parameters, but
they all take the ApiKey.
So as our first step for
test for GEt method, we can ensure that
the APIs included in our request by
adding it to our parameters dictionary,
that's past in the function.
And remember, this can change, because
the dictionary itself can change,
because we declared it
as a variable parameter.
Next, we need to build the URL
on the requested object.
So I've copied over the two and
three steps here from getSessionID, but
they need to be tweaked slightly, so
that we can construct the URL depending
on the method that we're using.
And remember, we pass in the method
strain as the first parameter for
taskForGETMethod.
So for the withPathExtension argument,
let's just change this to method.
Now let's create the request and start
to finding the completion handler for
the data task with request method.
In getSessionID, the first thing that
we do is to find the display error
function, but we don't need
that here in taskForGETMethod.
Instead, we'll let whoever calls task
for GET method handle any errors that
we pass back using that
completionHandlerForGET.
Remember, how when we looked at
taskForGETImage, I think it was.
Yep and login view controller that we
can respond to the image data that was
being passed back or the error that was
being passed back, that's where we're
going to let people respond to the
errors using this completion handler.
So, we're not going to add that here.
Instead, the first thing that we're
going to do is make these GUARD checks.
So, let's copy the GUARD statements
that we've been using all along and
let's move them over here.
And instead of calling it displayError,
we can use the completionHandlerforGET
to send the error back.
So I'll define a method
called sendError,
which is going to be similar
to our displayError.
It's going to construct
a NSError like we need and
then our result that it's going to pass
back is nil and then we can just simply
replace diplayError with sendError,
sendError and sendError.
There we go.
Now, we're ready to turn our JSON
into a usable dictionary after
we've made these GUARD checks.
Now, we can do that by
copying this code over or
we can use a method that's already
defined in the TMDB client and
that method is called
convertDataWithCompletionHandler.
So if we pass in our data and then it
also takes a completion handler and
this completion handler, its signature,
it matches the signature of
our completionHandleForGET.
So, let's do that and then let's go
down to see what this or we could scroll
down or we can click to see what
this method actually looks like.
Now, this method takes our data and then
it takes a completion handler or closure
matching the closure type that we saw
for what is it, completionHandlerForGET.
So let's go back down here and what
this is going to allowed us method to do
is to handle the converting of our
data into usable dictionary and
because it takes our completion handler,
it can call it.
So if this conversion into
usable dictionary fails,
then it can call our
completion handler and
it will pass nil for
the results and pass the NSError.
Our error with
the ConvertDataWithCompletionHandler.
Otherwise, it'll call it and
pass our results back,
our usable dictionary and
an error of nil.
And this will bubble backup to
where it's being called here,
which in turn, you can think of
it as bubbling back u to wherever
the completionHandlerForGET is defined,
so in our view controller.
It will bubble back up with either
the resulting data or our error and
the last thing we need to do is
to make sure we start the task,
which we already have that there and
that's it.
We now have a reusable method
that will make a GET request and
return some data or
an error from the movie database.
So next, we're going to do the same
thing for task for POST method.